by the way you know that one video that
you see with Jonah Hill being
interviewed and you know he's kind of
losing his cool and he says so you know
how does it feel like you're like that
fat guy in Hollywood right you're like
that fat guy in Hollywood's like can we
ask next question he said well I'm just
asking this because in Hollywood you
were the fat guy now you're the skinny
guy but you're still the fat guy does
that help your career and you can tell
he's getting irritated right and I think
he went to Jimmy Kimmel and Jimmy Kim
was like wow you actually smell very
good and he says why would you ask that
question I just didn't see you as
somebody that would smell very good why
not and he's not being funny he's
actually being irritated we're like dude
what are you doing so
when you see him uh going through what
he's going through and you you've you
know you've recreated yourself
does that hurt the brand because hey
who's the best guy that we can get that
can play XYZ it's Jonah okay let's get
him who's the best guy now we gotta does
it hurt the brand to position the actor
in a role that maybe would have worked
when he was not in shape instead of
being in shape typecasting essentially
does it hurt Jonah's brand or did it
hurt my brand both of you I mean I I
don't think it I don't think it hurt
Jonah's brain Jonah is a very very funny
person he's very witty he's written a
lot of the stuff that he's done so
that's a whole other Universe from what
I do I I don't do that I don't create
material for myself which you know if I
was capable of doing that maybe I'd have
a much better career than I do I'm very
happy with my career but you know what I
mean like Jonah Hills clearly on a much
higher level than I'm on
so I don't think it's hurt Jonah's brand
at all
um and if you see him now he's so happy
oh my God like his happy in his
happiness infects me I look at him and I
know there were there was a rough
package there right and and I think it's
I think and and I don't know we haven't
talked he's a buddy of mine too we
haven't talked that specifically about
this but it's got he something has
washed over him and he has let go of
something and he doesn't give a [ __ ]
anymore the media's out there trying to
you know the media does [ __ ] where they
try you know like they did it to me too
um now they're nice to him but there's a
minute where you lose weight and they
just want to criticize you and say like
you're not gonna get work or here's the
downside look at his loose skin look at
all these negative stuff and they were
doing that to him a little bit and he
just said [ __ ] you I don't care and and
and and he radiates inner peace and
happiness now like it's it's marvelous
for me yeah it's it's it's affected my
career a little bit I just had a movie
out you know
um a couple weeks ago called Dog which
I'm super happy I saw that yeah
congratulations thank you so it hasn't
kicked me out of Hollywood at all but
you know I also I also can look at my my
movie career prior to doing television
and going like well doing television
might have affected my movie career you
know what I mean and I lost a sizable
amount of weight at that point
doing television
is it is it is it a different it okay so
what's what's what's a promotion in your
world is it a feature or is it having a
television show that stays for three
four five six years what's well I'll
just put it to you this way the most
money I ever got paid for a movie was a
movie called Mr Woodcock which wasn't a
huge hit but it was a it was a fun movie
and the next thing I did was television
and I did television for five years and
you know if you if you do a television
show for seven months straight you want
to take those five months off you don't
want to go and do another movie so I'm
go there's Bob Thornton yeah so they're
coming banging a teacher or something
what was that what was that whole thing
about it he he was the the mean PE coach
okay that then starts hooking up with
one of the moms right and um you know
not Stifler's mom but uh right Stifler's
mom yeah that's not Stiffler in that
movie
um
coming out of my Name is Earl My Name is
Earl ends I've not done a movie in a few
years and now I'm like okay let's go do
movies again and movies were kind of
like well we you're a TV guy now you
know and so then it was doing pilots and
and more TV series so I you know I can't
say it's only weight loss that has you
know what I mean yeah so this paid you
the most most until today of any movie
of any movie yeah this paid you the most
wow what was your role in this movie can
you pull up
um I played his best friend and and me
and uh him were you know trying to track
down dirt on uh Woodcock to to break up
him and his mom
but see I wasn't I wasn't I wasn't at
that point as big as I was and Remember
the Titans not even not even close no
not even close you uh what what do you
weigh there no you're you're smart 300
pounds there
wow well back to the Jonah Hill thing
about I think there's there's a part and
even with your situation there's a part
of I think just the Human Condition I
don't know if it's Hollywood but when
you're so used to something and you
change you're like oh no that's not who
you are you're the fat guy what do you
what are you doing right right you know
yeah TV buddy yeah exactly that's part
of that once you do TV and it's like
it's a successful TV show people are
like no you're that character right when
you're doing movie after movie
especially me where I'm not a leading
man so I'm not the guy in the movie you
know Denzel Washington people probably
have some sense of I know who Denzel
Washington is right he's this guy right
and if he suddenly did a sitcom people
would be like what the [ __ ] is Denzel
Washington doing he's not a sitcom guy
you know where he's playing like the
goofy dad people would be freaked out I
would be freaked out yeah so would I
yeah
um
and so TV people you know the the other
differences it was explained to me once
was like um Brad Pitt I believe and I
could be totally off here Brad Pitt was
talking to Johnny Galecki Johnny Galecki
was on Roseanne and then um that math
sitcom I'm blanking on what it's called
Big Bang Theory yeah blonde dude no he's
got oh no no the glasses he was uh okay
it was Darcy's uh husband so Roseanne
Johnny Galecki had a hundred million
dollar contract on that show he was
making a fortune and and Brad Pitt said
to him yeah the difference between you
and me is you're inside their house
every week you're in their living room
I'm in a movie theater so people are not
coming up to me going hey like people
actually think they know you when you're
on TV versus when you're a movie star
there's some separation you gotta go and
and it might be changes very interesting
it might be changing now because a lot
of these movies are in the house too
immediately right but it's also not
serialized so it's like this is it this
is the movie you don't get uh an episode
two through possibly 100 of a movie
right but when you're when you're you're
kind of talked about like you're that
guy you're that I mean a lot of people
in Hollywood or even in TV struggle with
that I mean like dust and Diamond no
matter what role he ever did that was
screech yeah straight up Mario Lopez who
uh hosted one of uh Pat's
um big events Mario's been able to
navigate he's not AC Slater when you see
that guy still he's everywhere he's
everywhere I mean yeah
Hotel yeah and and the way my career
started in movies I was in American
History X and then Remember the Titans
and then blow those are three very very
different characters right and so you're
not I'm I'm
massive in all of them but you're not
pigeonholing me into oh I know
everything about that guy because then
the next week I'm doing something
completely different or the next so what
what do they say when they see you like
was it different based on different
movies that were out like when people
would see you in public what would it
what would they say it really is
it depends on their age and what their
is there an ever a person that was upset
with you because who you were in a movie
a role you played in a movie I have had
you know what I'm asking yeah you have
had a few people upset with uh American
History X and offended by it and I'm I'm
kind of perplexed because I think
American History X was actually an
important movie and and
painted a real picture of stuff that
happened especially from Los Angeles you
know Orange County in the 90s was a
scary place there were some bad dudes
down there that stuff existed I don't
think it really exists like that as we
portrayed it and I mean I'm sure there
are pockets in America but there were it
was easy to go down to Orange County and
find some racist skinheads in the 80s or
the 90s not so easy now
um but like it was important in that way
and so to have somebody just like the
language was bad you guys were so evil I
can't believe you did that it confuses
me yeah that that's that's kind of how I
process it like somebody comes oh you
you know what you you did this and
because emotionally you're connected in
movie you're like I can't believe you
killed them in a movie do you think
that's more related to TV shows though
or movies
but people don't seem to have a problem
with any of the TV shows I've done
really interesting but is that also due
to the characters because I know for
instance there are certain characters
like you mentioned in the TV shows where
they're in the in the living room week
after week year after year in many cases
and stuff like that where there's TV
shows where I think of a bad guy and
that's all I see him as even when you
see him in a movie in a different in a
different role you're like no you're
that Dirtbag from that from that TV show
yeah and I think that given that you're
in there longer and you're playing that
role as opposed to a movie where you're
a bad guy for two hours and then I go on
with my life
maybe that could be more of an offset as
opposed to the TV show I've played so
few bad guys I've played really like one
I'm trying to Rack my brain other than
American history like I don't think
there's another one that I've done where
I've been like a real legit bad guy is
that by choice or is that by casting I I
have nothing against playing a bad guy I
just haven't had many opportunities
together if you enjoyed the short clip
click over here to watch another short
clip and if you want to watch the entire
episode the entire podcast click here
[Music]